on va accueillir toute l'équipe bien sûr
de touche pas à mon poste
il arrive en zodiac je crois je crois
qu'ils s'en aillent au diable
[Musique]
mais balancer en veulent aux jo mais
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une première énigme toujours mon
premier n'est pas maigre 1 sur un compte
à mon premier n'est pas maigre un gros
mon deuxième n'est pas tout car mon
troisième n'est pas au aimons tous vous
correspond qui suis gros bâtard un gros
turn
le jeu est très simple la chine est il
en crise et où se trouvent dans ces
jarres déjà il peut avoir n'importe quoi
non mais n'importe quoi vous avez
exactement une minute pour trouver la
clé est ce qu'un monsieur de la sécurité
en corse a expliqué je suis là qu'elle
est je suis là pour toi là je vois des
trucs
c'est bien c'est un cafard ça rien je le
connais c'est un pote surtout on
respecte et anima oui j'allais doucement
encore kanye important et delphine ce
très important
qu'est-ce qu'il soit ce qu'elle est
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'allais avoir
une minute pour trouver la clé non à
chacun sa table chacun soit pas cédé
même genre c'est au jeu alors je vais
vous dire je découvre les versions wii
alors allez-y
delphine et delphine très bonne
animatrice en tout cas heureusement que
tu es là merci je dis attention je vais
donner le top 3 2 il ya pas une caméra
de nom pour ce qu'on voit ce qu'ils ont
commencé par là qu'elle bat celle que tu
veux attention c'est parti
3 2 a vous avez deux minutes pour
trouver la clé tadic est basique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut trouver la clé vous à 20h40 sur
jimmy kelly batterie basse à celui de
maxime
mais quoi c'est quoi ce salon auquel les
choses d'entre nous mais je vous le dis
c'est s'est passé pas grave ce soir un
conseil allez allez dans cela oui bien
c'est à l'esitpa les ai tous les lacs
watts dans une ambiance très belle
victoire mais là je sais pas ce que
c'est mais y'a rien cyril mais c'est
kelly pas anodine qui a quelque chose
yann clay et sérieux voilà des polices à
tanger c'est ok c'est le slip d'isabelle
[Applaudissements]
trois trucs à manger le premier acte
aura mangé les trois trucs sera gagné
peut-être une clé à quelqu'un du public
viendrait lui donner d'accord les cherry
et durera 3 que la fin et entend réussir
à remporter ce que vous êtes prêts à les
attentions à 2-3 tab à l'énoncé ryanair
j'allais très fort là dessus
attention s'il était mal à l'aise mais
j'ai vomi alors s'il vous plaît cette
existence hachette a donné cinq modèles
de merde salés sucrés merci a laissé un
goût de curry la tension très attention
deuxième option 1 2 3 se sont promis
bonjour monsieur le maire aujourd'hui
c'est à les regarder mais c'est fini
avec mes parents j'ai appelé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]